[Musique]
eh ben ça alors oui c'est impressionnant
j'avoue j'aurais adoré vivre dans un
endroit comme celui là quand j'étais
gamin
[Musique]
là c'est la calme
c'est malsain ici moi je trouve que ça a
du caractère c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
tu vas devoir descendre à la cave et
vérifier les fusibles et suis morte de
trouille il y a dix marches pour arriver
en bas tu les a comptés
voilà
elle et je suis sûr qu'elle n'a pas
fugué il s'est passé quelque chose de
cette cave quelque chose n'allait pas
steven maman à deux mois steven je peux
savoir ce que tu fais là dedans
il y avait quelque chose en a une
présence
en vous un peu expliqué l'histoire de
cette maison
votre équation est sans aucun doute la
représentation d'une dimension fou de
plusieurs dimensions vous avez vous
trouvé sa maman
tu as vu ses symboles de des portes
tout un sens tu le sais très bien chaque
image chaque mot ce sont les pièces d'un
puzzle c'est une évidence ce n'est pas
juste là car c'est la maison toute
entière tente
il est là
[Musique]